الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجيه لو وفائزه
الدويري وفائزه اهلا بك كيف تقرا هذه
المستجدات الميدانيه وكيف نضعها في اطار
المرحله من الهجوم المضاد وايضا من الرد
الروسي
يعني هناك عده نقاط لا بد من الاشاره
اليها اولا ما يجري في شبه جزيره القرن
منذ اربعه ايام كانت هي تاخذ اولويه اولى
في اطار العمليات الاوكرانيه وتوجت
بمهاجمه جسر القرم والتي لم تكن
العمليه الاولى انما تم استهداف ميناء
سلفاستوبل اذا دعينا نضعها تحت عنوان ما
هو مستقبل معركه شبه جزيره القرم في ظل
حديث قائد الحرس الوطني الاوكراني ورئيس
الاركان عن الجزم
باستعاده السيطره على شبه جزيره القرد اذا
هذه احد
مرتكزات مناطق العمليات الان لنذهب الى
المعارك الميدانيه هناك اربعه مناطق اذا
استثنينا شبه جزيره القرن نبدا من اقصى
الشمال في منطقه ليمان وهناك عمليات
روسيه عززت القوات بمئه الف مقاتل بدات
تحقق انجازات بدات التصريحات الاوكرانيه
تشير الى تلك الانجازات لكن هذه المقاربه
نهايتها لا تزال رماديه غير معروفه هل
تنجح القوات الروسيه بالسيطره على الايمان
والاندفاع الى سلافيانس وكرامه رزق وقلب
الصفحه على القوات
الاوكرانيه يقابلها عمليات عسكريه في
منطقه باكموت تقدمات محدوده جنوب باخمه
لصالح القوات الاوكرانيه لا ترقى الى
مستوى التقدمات الروسيه في منطقه الايمان
لنذهب جنوبا الى دونيست هناك هجمات روسيه
على اطراف مدينه دونسك شرق وغرب مدينه
لاستعاده السيطره عليها لكن ما يثير
الانتباه هو تصاعد العمليات في منطقه خرس
الان هناك محاولات لعبور نهر الدينيبر
هناك محاولات لتحقيق تقدمات هذه
هذا الجزئيه التي لم يتم التركيز عليها
علينا ان نربطها بما يجري في شبه جزيره
القرم اذا ربطنا ما يجري في خرسون مع ما
يجر يجري في القرم هذا يعني ان اتجاه
العمليات الرئيسيه سيتم نقله من الشمال
والوسط الى الجنوب لكن النهايات رماديه
على كافه مسرح العمليه
حتى الان كما كما ذكرت غير معلوم
طبيعه التقدم الروسي او حتى الدفاع
الاوكراني وغير ذلك على اكثر من محور في
الشرق لكن لو عدنا الى شبه جزيره القرم
تحديدا والتي تتركز عليها الانظار الان
هل تبدو السياسه الاوكرانيه العسكريه
متركزه حاليا على شبه جزيره القرم
باستهدافات متتاليه وكيف يتوقع هنا ان
يكون الرد
الروسي على استهدافات مستمره
غير الرسمي بعض المتحدثين يشير الى ضروره
استهداف مراكز صنع القرار المسؤوله عن
التخطيط لهذه العمليات الباكوره الرد جاءت
في القصف لثلاثه رئيسيه من اوديسيا الى
مايكولايف الى خارقه ولكن اتوقع ان الرد
سيكون اعنف واقوى قد يكون في الساعات
القادمه في الايام القادمه سياخذ بعدا
يستخدم
البنيه التحتيه بشكل رئيسي
وسيتهدف بعض نقاط ارتكاز صنع القرار في
العاصمه الاوكرانيه
الخليل العسكري والاستراتيجي اللواء فايز
الدويري هدفنا من عمان